it's officially Kito season so of course
I had to bring you guys my amazing
delicious Kito so let's get into the
full recipe so we're going to start off
by making our tea which is water
allspice cinnamon cloves and staranise
and we'll bring that to a light boil
steep it strain it cool it next we're
going to take Coco Lopez cream of
coconut coconut milk evaporated milk and
sweet condensed milk along with some
vanilla extract and some cinamon and
blend that up at this point your coito
should be nice and thick and then you
are going to begin adding a little bit
of that tea and of course Don which is
authentic Puerto Rican rum I like to use
the donq 151 it is strong and then I
also go in with their light ROM I add in
some cinnamon and guys when I tell you
this Kito recipe is sweet it's nice and
thick it's creamy the full recipe will
be on my blog enjoy guys to drink the
coito